even three weeks after launch destiny
two's forsaken expansion feels in some
ways overwhelming for all but the most
dedicated players it was nearly
impossible to be prepared for the raid
in the ten days between launch and its
release that's partially the fault of
now resolved issues that prevented
players from leveling up properly but
it's also indicative of just how far
destiny 2 has swung in the hardcore
direction however a strong foundation of
more accessible activities coupled with
an engaging new campaign and a fantastic
new mode in gambit help make up for
prohibitive level restrictions in the
late game after two disappointing
expansions
this is the best shaped destiny 2 has
been in you just have to be patient with
it assemble Cades death at the beginning
of the campaign starts you off on a
journey for revenge which means hunting
down and killing those responsible eight
barons powerful enemies from the new
scorn race the boss focus structure in
darker tone make for a more interesting
and varied campaign where each mission
feels like a necessary step rather than
busy work with no clear narrative
purpose that said it's not so involved
that you can't run through the missions
with others and talk over some of the
dialogue without losing track of what
your goals are the entry level portion
of the game can take ten or so hours
with some grinding in-between depending
on whether you go solo or with a
fireteam of one or two others once you
finish that campaign you unlock the
second destination the Dreaming city the
level requirements jump quite a bit
which means a good amount of grinding
completing weekly challenges for
powerful gear to get there
depending on how dedicated you are this
can either be a laid back process over
time or a grueling one over a few days
as is the case with destiny 2 in general
the strength of its shooting mechanics
in the lore of new weapons and armor
helped to offset the repetition inherent
to the mid-game grind structure
the standout addition to the rotation is
gambit a part pvp part PvE mode that has
you competing with an enemy team on
mostly separate Maps your main goal is
to kill ai-controlled enemies collect
the motes they drop and Bank those motes
to summon a final boss before the other
team summons and kills theirs along the
way members from each team will have the
opportunity to invade the other map and
score PvP kills to screw with their
opponent's progress it's a creative
combination of Destiny's various
existing modes and having to juggle both
your side of the map and the other
team's progress and frantically trying
to hide when an invader comes makes for
hectic matches that are consistently fun
with or without friends as well as a
great way to level up regardless of your
commitment after about a week of playing
and leveling daily I was in good shape
to tackle what The Dreaming City has to
offer
the two main activities are the blind
well and the ascendant challenge the
blind well is a high-level Horde style
public event that comes in a few tiers
of difficulty even if you're with a
fireteam you'll likely have to wait
around for a bit for a few people to
show up before you can start the harder
tiers and then you have to hope that
they know what they're doing it's
frustrating when you aren't gelling with
randoms and end up failing but it's
extra gratifying when you do sync up
with a group and complete the higher
tiers the ascendant challenge on the
other hand is not public and is best
tackled with a fireteam completing both
Nets you a few pieces of high-level gear
which is always a strong incentive this
close to the endgame but even three
weeks after launch it was difficult to
get a raid crew together three of us
were playing and leveling at a fast pace
- were playing relatively often between
other work duties and one was splitting
time between PC and ps4 and was severely
underleveled at 5:13 but powering
through it admirably we were able to
take on the first encounter of the raid
but the severe spikes and level
requirements made it nearly impossible
like other destiny raids though the
communication teamwork and skill
required to succeed makes for an
intensely satisfying experience it's
just frustrating that it's been such an
uphill battle to get there there is a
lot to do in forsaken so much so that it
can be difficult to see it all there's
also been a consistent rollout of
content since the raid was first
completed with the possibility of more
to come that means that for the average
player this expansion has a much longer
tail than previous iterations of destiny
to the
and flexibility of activities
established in the base game still work
to make grinding a good time and gambit
adds a consistently entertaining mode to
the roster in the end game while
difficult to reach is also where the
most satisfaction can be found even if
it does require a bit of patience
forsaken is a dense and rewarding
expansion
now take it
[Music]